Variables are called variables because they can vary. Here's a variable. It's
initial value is 228, but I can vary that if the need arises. Maybe the trip
took longer than I thought. Here I'm setting the variable to a different value.
Note that. The declaration looks almost the same as the assignment, where I
assign a new value to an existing variable. The only way you can tell them
apart is that the assignment has no type. The declaration has the type in here.
The assignment looks just like a declaration except there's no type. That tips
us off that traveltime is an existing variable, whereas over here where we say
int traveltime, it is a new variable. One way of thinking about a variable is
as a little box with a name. Of course, the value is inside the box, and it can
vary. As a result, of such an assignment. Now we've assigned a new value, to
the variable, and the new value is stored, in the little box.